All right,
the next session is going to be the
final session of this symposium.
It's been a really incredible journey,
and I think this final session is going
to be great as well. So we have
a whole panel here,
and people can
use their cameras, even though I'm not
if they want to welcome everyone,
I'll just introduce the facilitator,
Kurt Jamungol. So Kurt is a legend
in the active ecosystem and has done
incredible work with a variety of
researchers and curious individuals in
the space, so we could think of no one
better to host this conversation and
bring it all together. So, Kurt,
I'll pass it to you. You'll keep an eye
on the live chat. Anyone can call it if
they need any supports. Otherwise,
thanks, everybody, for joining.
And we don't see you yet, Kurt.
But yeah, it would it be all right if I
left and then came right back? For
whatever reason, my camera is not
working. Sounds good. Sounds good.
Okay, I'll be right back in about 25
seconds.
Well, welcome, everyone.
We will get started in just a second.
It's so
odd. I apologize for that. Okay,
well, you can hear my voice, at least.
Yes, just give me a moment.
Boy. Okay,
well, we'll do what we can. Okay,
so you all can't see me, but that's
all right. So we have this all star
panel here today, which to me means my
invitation must have been a mistake,
but I'll take it. Thank you to the
active inference institutes. And I'll go
around this virtual zoom table and
introduce everyone briefly. Karl Friston
is the welcome Principal Research Fellow
and Scientific Director at the welcome
Trust Center for Neuroimaging and
professor of Neurology at University
College London. He's also the chief
scientist at Versus. Anna Lempke
is chief of the Stanford Addiction
Medical sorry. Medicine dual diagnosis
clinic at Stanford University. Her
popular books include Drug Dealer, MD
and Dopamine Nation.
Raphael Kaufman is CTO of Digital
Gaia and the onboard sorry. And is on
the board of directors of the Active
Inference Institute. Bert DeVries is a
professor at Eindhoven University of
Technology, where he directs the Bias
Lab research team and also works with
industry. Guillaume Dumas is an
associate professor in computational
psychiatry of the Faculty of Medicine at
the University of Montreal and the
Director of the Precision, Psychiatry
and Social Physiology Laboratory in Chu
St. Sorry. In the Chu
St. Justine Research Center. He's also
affiliated with Mila or Mila,
which is Quebec's Artificial
Intelligence Institute and other art,
science and consciousness service
initiatives. My name is Kurt Chamongle,
and I use my background in mathematical
physics to analyze various theories of
everything that are proposed. These
include both the theoretical physics
side of grand unification with gravity
and dualities other schemes, as well as
attempting to understand what
constitutes consciousness. You can find
the podcast by typing in theories of
everything onto YouTube or whatever
podcast catcher you have. So my question
to everyone. The initial question is
what have you been working on in the
past few months and what excites you
about it? We'll start with Bert.
You seem to be smiling and your
name sounds like mine.
Okay. All right, so my name is
Bertovis, and yeah. I lead a lab in
an electrical engineering department.
And so our lab is called Bislab, as you
mentioned. So we are interested in
Bayesian inference in general, but more
specifically in doing it as fast as
possible. That has lots of applications
outside active inference, also for
signal processing and other control
systems, but definitely, of course,
also for active inference. So half our
work over the past few months, but even
over the past few years has been on
developing a toolbox to support or to
get as far as we can go with trying to
do real time Bayesian inference or real
time free energy minimization and trying
it in applications.
So that's the work that I
try to lead a team of PhD students who
do the real work. Of course, I walk
around with a cup of coffee, but that's
what they've been working on.
Great. And Professor Lemke, please.
Yeah, well, what I've been working on in
the last, I don't know, year or so is
spending a lot of time thinking about
how it is that a faith framework in
particular surrendered to a higher
power, improves people's lives.
And I've been really struggling to come
up with a way of talking about this that
is inclusive. Thinking about it,
talking about it, it gets to a
kind of core piece of it that I'm
interested in, which is not so much
whether or not God exists and what the
proof is or not of whether God exists.
But really, what is it that changes in
people's lives when they undergo a
spiritual transformation, when they
surrender to a higher power? Why do
their lives get better when they do get
better? And I'm really new to the active
inference world. Daniel Friedman is the
one who's introduced me to these ideas.
I'm really excited about the ways in
which the whole active inference model
might help me at least think about
what's going on.
I'm that's what I'm working on. It's a
little weird, but that's what I'm
interested in. Great. Professor Friston,
you're muted. Yes,
that's going to be the title of my next
book. Karl, you're on mute retro
from the possibly the future.
I generally work on what I'm told to
work on, so I'm just trying to list what
I've been working on in the past few
months. Interestingly. It actually
starts with Daniel Friedman and his
fascination, along with Axel constant
for evolutionary explanations that speak
to many of the scale free issues that
we've been hearing about in the prior
session. So that's what I was working
on, really. A scale free approach to
understanding temporary nested processes
as free energy minimizing processes as a
kind of active inference and how that
would lead to a variational synthesis of
evolution. And then I was told to work
on belief sharing by Mahault and
colleagues at Versus and
worked on that in the context of
synthetic language and tried to
establish a really simple proof of
principle that communication was an
emergent property of any free ensemble,
free energy minimizing system.
And just to open brackets, just to make
the observation, it struck me time and
time again during the session today how
important communication is, whether
we're talking about Bert's passing
messages or responding to you've got
a new posterior, or we're talking about
the kind of communication that Mahault
was talking about. Well, everybody's
been talking about. It does seem to be
really, indeed, the Gaia notion
of overconnectivity and too much
communication or the wrong kind of
communication. It does strike me that's
quite central to both the theme
of the workshop and
the specific presentations that we've
heard. And then in the past few weeks,
working on stuff I think that Bert would
be more interested in, which is fast
and frugal message passing schemes that
enable the evaluation of the expected
free energy, not to suffer from the
limitations imposed by deep tree
searches. So possibly Ashwin has
spoken about this earlier on, but you're
using ideas from dynamic programming,
backwards induction to try and take
the pressure off the message passing to
get fast and efficient evaluations of
the expected free energy in sort of
single unit, single agent active
inference. What have I been doing this
week? Can't remember.
That's what I've been doing. Great.
Raphael kaufman, please.
Just a moment.
Can everyone else hear? Okay.
What about now? Yeah, great. Yeah,
thanks. It's contagious, I think. So
I've also been drinking a lot of coffee
as I've been caring for my now nine
month old daughter.
Congratulations. Thank you. So aside
from sleep deprivation, what I've been
doing is I
told you guys about this in the session
earlier today, but in a nutshell, we've
been working on what we call the Gaia
Protocol, or the Gaia network, which is
this open approach for
building a common engine. Think of
it as a common runtime and a common
language with the building blocks of
shared decision making in
the context of the Med crisis,
and getting to a set of
building blocks for decision making that
don't kill us all. So that's kind of it.
Rafael, how much coffee is a lot of
coffee? Well, it's espresso,
so I don't think it's quite comparable
to American coffee. All right.
And Guillaume dumas, please. Yes, sure.
Can you hear me? Yes. Okay.
So in the context of active inference,
I have mostly focused on, well, the two
big topics of my lab. So precision
psychiatry and social physiology. So.
On the precision psychiatry side, ninka
Boyton presented earlier in this
symposium our work on trying to model
theory of mind to being able to
evaluate, through digital phenotyping,
the level of sophistication of
interaction in patients with
neurodevelopmental disorders. And that
connect with also our interest in the
social mind and how we can connect our
understanding of how we deal with other
people but with also ourselves. And so
that connect with other work at the
mila, with deep learning architecture,
with higher order function
in humans, where we're trying to combine
different theories of consciousness,
such as global neural workspace and
attention schema theory. And in the
context of attention schema theory,
there is this kind of recycling of self
and other mechanisms. So that's one
big work. And on the other side, I'm
very interested also in multi agent
systems. And so with Natalie Castell,
who's going to join us soon,
we've been working on creativity and the
emergence of cultural norms in multi
agent systems with the idea of applying
that to climate action. And also a new
project that is starting here with NFRF
of a big Canadian project on Indigenous
knowledge and how we can think about new
narrative around AI and typically a less
solipsistic and individualistic way of
dealing with AI. So that's the two main
field of research. Can you explain what
you mean by less solidistic, less
solipsistic when it comes to AI.
The Californian view of AI, because the
narrative is mainly driven by us
and California right now tends to circle
around optimization profits. I mean,
even OpenAI states that AGI
is about optimizing profitable
human tasks. They put like profitable in
their definition. In the case of
Indigenous systems of knowledge, we are
more talking about community
sustainability. And the
view already only in the application is
less individualistic. But also in the
cognitive science point of view, we have
the outcore computationalism that could
say the brain is just like a computer in
a very restrictive sense. And so AI,
like, typically those transformers that
are massively used right now are kind of
like brain in a VAT in a very silicon
sense, while we are embodied systems
that are constituted by our interaction
with others. And so, in a way, how we
can think about artificial intelligence
in this kind of more co constitutive way
and through a developmental and cultural
lens. Okay, now, speaking of the
brain as a computer, we frequently hear
in these circles the brain as a
predictive machine. So where does this,
the quote unquote brain as a predictive
machine have its limits? And also, is
that to be interpreted as implying
conscious experience is a predictive
machine as well? And if not, why not?
So I think, Karl, you'd be a great
person to start this off, and then we'll
go around the table again.
Yeah, I was mindful of Mao's
presentation the past half hour and the
notion of temporal thickness.
I'm sure that's got a lot to do with the
necessary conditions for the kind of
consciousness. I'm guessing you're
referring to that freedom from the
moment. And if one reads prediction
in its sort of psychological or
protension nature in terms
of being able to predict what will
happen in the future. I think that's
going to be sort of a key bright line
between things that do not possess
certain kind of sentience and things
that do. And that bright line just rests
basically upon well, from perspective of
active inference having a generative
model that includes the consequences of
your own actions in the future. So just
by having consequences you're now
talking about the future and
the consequences in the future now
become random variables. Therefore you
have to infer them. Which leads you
directly to the notion of planning as
inference, which means that bright line
is just a difference between things that
plan and do not plan. And I
would guess that that's where you
probably want to start in terms of
foregrounding the role of prediction as
being an aspect of
self organization and its sort of
reading under active inference that
characterizes conscious things from non
conscious things, namely the ability to
plan. Does that make sense?
I have follow up questions. We'll get to
them at some point, but for now, Anna,
do you have any comments on that and
Bert as well afterward?
Well, I'm new to this field so I'm just
familiarizing myself even with the
language. But I can respond to the
question. The brain is a predictive
machine in terms of the work that I do
clinically and the kind of
psychopathology that I see when I'm
working with patients,
I work primarily with narrative, the
stories that they tell about their
lives. And one of the recurring themes
I've seen through my work is that when
patients tell stories in which they are
perpetually the victims of other
people's actions or the world,
that tends to be a predictive model for
them so that they will then go out into
the world and unconsciously create
scenarios which will perpetuate their
victimhood. And that part of getting
into wellness is to stop seeing
themselves as entirely the victim of
other people or circumstance, instead
begin to appreciate what they contribute
to their life problems. So I guess when
I think of the limits of the brain as a
predictive machine, I think in some ways
one of the big limits is that it's a
very powerful predictive machine that
actually allows us to subsequently shape
what actually happens to us and or our
perceptions of what happens to us,
which then can perpetuate a false
narrative. And I'll just give one small
example from my own life. I've had my
conflicts with my mother and one of my
beefs about her is that she's a very
poor communicator and that whenever I
email her I either get a cryptic
response or no response at all and it
drives me crazy. And about five years
ago she sent an email, asked me some
questions, I wrote her back and
responded and it was clear to me that
that required yet a response from her
which I never got. And that then
perpetuated my narrative about her as a
very poor communicator and many other
negative things. And then about three
months after I sent that email, I found
the email in my draft box. So I
had never actually responded to my
mother's email. I hadn't actually sent
the email. And that was, for me, just a
personal, wonderful example of the ways
in which our actions
can actually be
manipulated to support our
models and perpetuate falsehoods
about the world that we live in.
Right. And I have a quick question,
Bert, just for Anna before we get to
you. So you use the word narrative
there. How are you defining the word
narrative? Is it the same as model? Is
it a sequence of events? Like, what is
the specific definition of narrative? I
never really thought about it in those
terms. But when I talk about narrative,
I'm talking about the
stories that people tell about their
lives, because that's sort of my data
and also about models, because what I've
discovered about self narrative is it's
not just a way to organize the past. It
also becomes a roadmap for the future.
That's the language that I use, but I
see it maps very nicely onto Ural's
language of modeling the world. I see.
Professor DeVries, please.
Yeah, it's clear that the ability
to predict is the essence of intelligent
decision making. Yeah, I have a
different background. Right. I'm not a
psychiatrist, so I think about these
things in different way. The thing that
I think about when I think about
prediction is I would assume that brain
predicts far ahead, that things
get less accurate. Right. If I predict
that I want to go three quarters around
a roundabout. I don't care about the
centimeter where my car goes when I'm
around there, I just want to get in the
right lane. And I would assume that the
brain doesn't takes less computations if
you care about things less precisely.
But that's very hard in a computer.
This is what kind of kills us,
I think, in our current way of
implementing active inference. When we
want to predict a deep hat, we don't
care about the accuracy, but we don't
know how to do it much cheaper when
things are less accurate. And so that's
a problem that we need to be working on.
It might be a key to building or to
scaling up active entrance agents if we
can actually compute messages that
we want to know that we don't care
about, if they are less precise, that we
also spend much less computation on
them. Thank you.
Now, Professor Kaufman.
I am not a professor, but I'll answer
anyway. Can just call me Rafa.
Rafa. Yeah. So there's
so many really interesting avenues here,
and it's not often that I get the
pleasure of discussing this kind of
stuff with this kind of diverse crowd.
But I've been interested in
these questions for a pretty long time.
And I think what comes to mind is
how active inference at the lens,
for instance, it enables us to
get another sense of what nondualist
views on consciousness are saying when
they get us experientially to notice
the difference. Between what we actually
perceive and between the different
various different processes or things
that are going on in our head and our
tendency to lump them all together into
the same okay. This is my
experience that I'm immersed in.
So noticing being able to notice
the difference between the
process of perceiving and acting and to
an extent, it's automated, and the
narrative or the various narratives that
are going on in parallel in
my head, whether I'm aware of them or
not. And our ability
to just put kind of seemingly arbitrary
manner levels on top of it, to try to
make sense of it all and to force
that experience of having multiple
narratives and multiple framings going
on at the same time make sense of that
experience.
In a. Way that aligns with our
presuppositions about how things are.
So I think that's super interesting.
I also want to highlight that this
view of consciousness as being kind of
defined by having a narrative or an
internal model that's about self or that
at least is about self. And that leads,
as Karl said, to planning this inference
that's actually, like, super
deflationary in a way that people are
not used to thinking about exciting.
It's opening the doors to all sorts of
exciting interdisciplinary conversations
to be had on the basis of at least, I
feel like, better, less talking past
each other than we've ever had. So I'm
excited about that. And how is it
that you're using the word deflationary
there, Karl? I remember I asked you
about that when we had our podcast
together. But Rafael, similar question.
So you said deflationary view. When we
have narratives of self, do you mean us
to something that consciousness is much
more than sorry. Much,
yeah. It's not necessarily much less
than in the subjective sense, but it's
perhaps much less than in the
scientific sense. So one example of not
saying exactly that, but maybe something
close to what Daniel Dennett calls
hetero phenomenology, which is basically
the statement that the sum of what one
can say scientifically about
consciousness is is
equal to what? Can be studied and
modeled and theorized and communicated
and learned and agreed upon on the basis
of objective data about what people,
including you, but also other people say
about their experience and, of course,
what can be measured. Up neuro,
correlates and whatever. Which is not
the same as not necessarily the same as
our experience of what we think is our
direct experience of being conscious.
Right. So one way to look at it is that
the science of consciousness doesn't
necessarily have to put the primacy on
people. For instance, people saying they
have qualia, that we thought in that
sense it's deflationary. Right.
You have to explain why people believe
they have qualia, not why people have
qualia because it's not necessarily a
scientific truth that people have.
Right, Professor Dumas.
Yes. Well, on the limits of brain as
predictive machine, well, we should be
always careful to not move from one map
territory fallacy to another one for
sure. So we need to be skeptics
and avoid to refine the methods. And
well, this World symposium show how this
metaphor is super useful and fruitful,
but I can see like two main limits
or at least things where we should be
careful. So following what
Professor Lemke said in psychiatry, I
think the looping effects and
the way people picture themselves can
be very unpredictable. And so the
way we think about the brain as
a predictive machine think prediction
for patients would have different
signification of what we mean by
predictive machines in the context of
active inference and in general. Also,
I can see that certain psychologists
or anthropologists would have a big
appeal all of a sudden for active
inference and free energy principles,
but taking the words as
directly what they think the word mean,
where we need to be careful in the way
to communicate it. And typically
following also what Professor Debris
said about prediction as being super
important for decision making, I think
we should be careful about the weirdness
of cognitive science and how it doesn't
necessarily expand to non Western
educated industrialized country, where
maybe the cultural value is not about
optimization of your decision making or
your profit. And so that's the first
thing where I think we should be
careful. It's more like a matter of how
to communicate the theory in that case,
not necessarily a limit of the theory
itself, but the second one is
about the equivalents or not with
other. Like,
I can see we had Mahault
Albasan talking about category theory.
And I'm very curious about right now
among the different frameworks that are
out there, how can we define what is
equivalent or not with active inference
to be able to see those limits? Maybe we
are leaving what happened with quantum
mechanics in the early 20th
century with different interpretation,
with different tools to model quantum
mechanics, and here with artificial
intelligence and cognitive neuroscience,
we have also all those frameworks. And I
think the limitation would be then to
not take this interpretation as the only
one, but try to have a cross talk and a
differential diagnosis of which one is
the best for explaining what.
Okay, now my role is the moderator, but
I would like you all to speak to one
another. So I'm going to ask a question
that will serve as well. You each will
speak on it, but as the other person is
speaking sorry, as the other people are
speaking, just think, okay, is there a
question that I have or is there a
comment that I have? So the question is
what are some of the recent advancements
or breakthroughs in your respective
fields that you find particularly
promising and well recent,
let's say 2020 till now so
we'll start off with Raphael you're
smiling and you look like. You'Re
champion I was thinking what is my
field? Right? Because.
We'Re very much in
the last mile of applying the wonderful
stuff that y'all come up with and making
it useful on the so
I'm extraordinarily excited about
research like what Bird is doing.
And I
feel like, as Gion was saying, we're
also starting to see some convergence on
different ways
to get. At. Least the same
shape of answers and in some cases,
even to the same result.
So one example of this is work
that Chris Fields,
Karl and others have been doing on the
quantum basically
explaining quantum information theory
and how it relates to the free energy
principle. Looking at the free energy
principle as the classical limit of
quantum information theory and I don't
pretend to understand all of it, but as
somebody who is coming from a quantum
physics background just being alive to
see this kind of conversions happening
which as I mean, as Guillaume said,
we've been at this business of post
classical what the hell is going on for
over a century now and it's nice to be
at a time where again we're starting to
talk less past each other and that's
from a theoretical perspective, from a
practical perspective, I think just
finding that we have all the building
blocks to create fast,
interpretable,
reliable and aligned decision making
systems which includes AI systems,
autonomous systems that have all those
characteristics and that it turns out
that all the things that the
reinforcement learning and deep net
neural networks people talk were very
hard or impossible are sort of in the
realm of what we can do looking at
things from an active inference lens and
vice versa. A lot of things that active
inference models have incorporated so
far, it turns out if you toss in a
neural network approximator here and
borrow some other massively parallel
computation techniques, it also becomes
feasible. So it's converging.
Yeah. For me, what's remarkable is
that there's so many domains of what we
thought was exclusively human or would
be exclusively human for decades that
in just the past couple years robots or
computers seem to be just as good, if
not exceeding us. And I don't know if
that's promising or worrisome, but
anyhow Karl, please, if you don't mind
answering the question. And then we'll
go. Anna then Bert and then Dumas.
Actually, just reflecting upon one
of your observations I think it's very
difficult to identify one thing.
In a sense,
what is impressive is the diversity of
advances and applications.
And I just say that because that's what
I was thinking over the past 6 hours,
just listening to your amazing
presentation after presentation and just
noting how diverse and yet
there's this common thread, this common
commitment, basically stating our
curiosity and using the tools that
naturalize, that kind of sense making,
curious behavior and communication that
inherit from sort of either maths or
category theory or as Ralph notes now,
quantum information theory. But just to
pick up on a couple of things which are
relevant to this conversation. So the
work with Chris Fields, it sounds lovely
and exciting to bring quantum mechanics
into active inference,
but that's not the move that I think
Chris is really wanting to champion.
The move, I think, is something that
we've all been addressing in one way or
another, which is leveraging the scale
free aspects of this principled
approach to self organization and
hopefully self organization to some kind
of generalized synchrony.
So that's where the quantum information
theory gets into the game. It is scale
free. And indeed, he will go further and
say it's completely background free and
everything is constructed. So I think
that's a lovely move, because once
you've gone scale free, you then start
to ask deep questions about how you
couple one scale to another scale. And
in a sense, ecosystems is just that.
How do the denizens of an ecosystem,
how is it constituted? How is it co
constructed? What is the structure of
it? These are all questions about how
one scale links to another scale. So I
think there have been lots of advances
in that direction in many, many
different fronts. And you can read that
either in terms of coupling, difference
of spatial or spatial
scales, but probably more importantly,
sort of temporal scales. And you see
that wherever you look,
you'll just come back to what do you
mean by a narrative? It is exactly I
think, as I said, it's just a plan.
It's just a story. But notice the story
has a temporal aspect to it. I have
narratives about being a good person,
being a good father, being a good
scientist. I also have narratives about
I want my cup of coffee, or I have to go
look after the I don't, but Ralph has to
go look after the child. So we've
all got narratives at very, very
different timescales. And of course, if
you're I just came back to Bert's
example of I'm an autonomous vehicle and
I'm sentient and we're five years into
the future, and I have to drive around
the roundabout. What temporal scale and
what kind of temporal course grading to
define the narratives necessary with
narratives would be appropriate for that
kind of situation and the
ensuing planning.
Short answer to your question. I think
there have been many, many advances.
I think what they've had in common is
basically transcending either different
domains, but in particular different
scales of application. I also agree with
the notion. Well, another I think,
important and pragmatic advance is
something that Bert mentioned, which is
democratization of this technology. I
think Ralph also hinted at this is the
time you start using this for the common
good. So.
I think things like RX infer
and PMDP. And I didn't know about
the Gaia project, but it sounds as
though there's been great advances there
as well. So this kind of
democratization, I think, is really
important, this sort of socialization
where everybody can play and start to
sort of not talk past each other. I
think that's a very
important advance. And did you say the
word scale invariance or scale
independence? I said scale invariant.
I actually said scale free, and I
shouldn't have done that.
I said scale free. So the idea
that you can apply exactly the same
mechanics and literally, for example,
say, from Bert's perspective, the same
kind of message passing at different
space time scales or at
different levels in a hierarchical
model. So I've actually got a question
for Bert in terms of reactive message
passing, because reactive means that
you don't have to prescribe the
scheduling, but in addressing
the problems or the issues that
entailed, by having to specify the
scheduling of talking or of message
passing, you're bound
to deal with time.
And in a scale invariant
context, or nested with nested scales,
for example, you have to deal with the
separation of temporal scales. So I
think there's going to be a very
important generic question, which
technically Bert will have been thinking
about furiously for the past few years.
But I think implicitly, we're all going
to have to be addressing soon, which is,
how do you put the timing of your
messages when you make a move or when
you listen to a patient, or when
you actually pass a message on a
Factograph? How are we going to
be able to put the separation of
timescales into the architecture in a
way that speaks to this scale?
Invariance the Gear project, for
example, how do you integrate live feed
from traffic flow sensors
with fluctuations in the climate?
This kind of data comes at very, very
different temporal scales and yet has to
be assimilated and modeled in
a way that also, I think, has to know
due courtesy to that separation of
temporal scales. Bert, could you please
recapitulate the question for the
audience and then begin to answer it?
Okay, yeah. The issue is active
instance agents are nested agents, and
the higher levels supposed to operate
on a larger temporal scale,
but they are also working at
a lower resolution. If you look far
ahead, you don't care as much about
precision, not at a centimeter level.
When I go around about, I don't care at
the centimeter where I land, but for the
next few milliseconds, I do care because
it may mean the difference between
getting in the ditch or not.
So the higher level, I want to look very
deep ahead, but I don't want to send
every millisecond a message to go to
look, let's say, a minute ahead.
So I need to space it out a lot, but
then I may miss things. So preferably
you would just send inaccurate messages.
But that only works if you actually have
a method to also, let's say,
use less computational power to compute
a less accurate message. And we're not
good at that yet.
What we are thinking about is there's a
new field or a new field, but there's a
field called probabilistic numerics
where we are used in
math to just compute everything very
precisely or as precise as possible and
do not care about how much computation
we spend on it. So in probabilistic
numerics, I hope we can leverage this
for message computations. I would like
to spend, let's say, proportionally less
computational power on the accuracy of
a message. One way possibly would be to
consider a message a latent variable
that has uncertainty by itself.
But I don't have a totally clear answer
for Karl because we haven't solved that
either. But there is a
problem in, let's say, what we do on our
computers were so completely different
from computers, let's say, from the from
the from the brain, that,
yeah, we are spending we're spending
just too many computations on messages
that in the end are very inaccurate.
And that's a problem in what we do on
our computers currently.
Yeah. So I don't know how we go what
you want to do with this on the higher
level. If you want to look maybe ten
times farther ahead and spend about the
same amount of computation on the lower
level, that's sort of our goal.
But we don't have an answer for that
either at the moment.
Anna so please feel free to comment on
or ask a question to.
I don't I don't have anything to
contribute, unfortunately, to how
computers work. But I can tell you that
this idea of temporal scales is
something that we face often in our work
with patients. For example, addicted
patients are very focused on short term
rewards and, in fact, their ability
to control how they feel in the moment,
that is partially what drives the
addiction. So when I try to adopt Ural's
language of minimizing surprise or
minimizing free entropy, that's one of
the things that people are trying to do
on a short term scale when they become
addicted. So I have a young woman who's
addicted to nitrous oxide, which has a
very fast onset of intoxication over the
order of seconds and a very fast offset,
and she says that that's exactly what
she likes about it, because she's
controlling it second by second. So when
we work with patients to get them out of
that short temporal horizon, we actually
rely more and more on action and having
them change something in their lives,
namely abstain from their drug of choice
for long. Enough to kind of completely
reset their brains and to allow them to
see this longer temporal, because when
they're chasing this short control,
they're actually not able to see
themselves in the longer narrative arc
of their lives. So that's what comes
to mind for me. I don't think it's going
to be helpful to people who are trying
to build computers, but that's the kinds
of interventions that I make with
humans. I have a question about that.
So you mentioned control in the short
term, and you've also mentioned that you
study the positive effects of
having a higher power in your life or
surrender. Okay. I kind of gave the
punchline away by saying surrendering to
the higher power. Where I was going was,
okay. What's the association between
seeing yourself in the largest time
frame and a higher power? And then also
is there something that is akin to
giving up control when you
look farther and farther into the
future? Such a great yeah, that's at the
heart of what I'm very interested in,
because it's a real paradox, right?
It's this kind of locus of control
within ourselves that really, in modern
culture, we think is a great thing. But
when that's taken to an extreme and one
example of that is addictive behaviors.
It's very bad for people and for
communities. And so what can
pull people out of that is this kind of
surrender to a higher power, giving up
that locus of control, locating that
locus of control outside themselves,
not necessarily like in a theistic sense
one of the things that they talk about
in Alcoholics Anonymous, for example,
is you don't have to believe in God.
It's just not you. You're not driving
it. And so I would be very curious,
from the perspective of Ural's
understanding of active inference and
the free energy principle and how the
brain works, why is it that
sort of embracing our inability to
control what happens in our lives can
actually be the very source of healing,
especially embedded in this really kind
of over controlled? I would even go so
far as to say endemically narcissistic
culture. I'm really curious. I don't
want to take the conversation in a
direction please. That's a fantastic
question. So if anyone has a comment on
that, please.
I have some thoughts, and I think
this applies both at
the personal level and at the global
level. And I think it has to do with my
quote from earlier by Edward Fulbrook
that if you're falling from a plane,
yes, maybe an altimeter and some
instruments might be useful, but what
you really need is a parachute. Right?
So we have this
presupposition that whatever
framing we have operating in our day to
day is going to be, okay. This is the
right framing. And it tends to be this
rational, scientific framing of very
linear cause and consequence for
most stuff. And it turns out that even
if you inspect our day to day behavior,
bigger, more complicated models are not
necessarily better, which is where we
get the success of heuristics under
bounded computation. Bounded
rationality. And if
you scale it up to 8 billion humans
interacted in resource constrained
planet, a world of possibilities, but
also of challenges. Then we
have to drastically lower.
Our. Bar for, yes, how much macro we
have. But also even where does
information gathering reach diminishing
returns? Where does modeling reach
diminishing returns? There's a whole
literature in the business world about
the expected value of information, how
much you should actually invest. Also in
science is also known as optimal
experiment design, where basically
acknowledging that you have limited
budget in terms of how much you can act
and how much you can probe and how much
time you can spend thinking about stuff.
And I think what we're doing when we
feel like, burned out or exhausted
from overthinking, we're innately
feeling that, okay, we've gone too high
and we need to give ourselves
a vacation, give ourselves some free
time here. I think that doing this
principle in a principled way, we're
just not just like, taking the
heuristics and the signals that we
inherit from evolution, but actually
being able to figure out collaboratively
and with some rigor. Okay,
we don't need to know exactly how many
degrees the world is going to warm by
2000 and 2100. In order to know that
maybe it's a good idea to start doing
something about the amount of carbon in
the atmosphere or whatever. Right? And
so I think this leads to this
idea of a real knowledge economy and of
things like abstraction as a service.
How can you actually build
in these kind of sophisticated,
sophisticated translation layers that
take some of this burden from ourselves
as individuals and even as
organizations, right? And just put it
out in the world as value added
services, which is what they are.
And Guillaume, if you have any
statements or questions or retorts,
then please feel free. Yeah,
thanks. Now, I was still also thinking
about the recent breakthrough post 2020
in Action France.
To me, there were theoretical progress
that were very interesting. We heard
already about the formalism maturity at
the mathematical level between
multiscale and scale free aspects.
I really liked also the development of a
more multi agent perspective of active
insurance. It's very interesting,
especially like, for instance,
seeing multi agent systems. We just
heard about even society as a wall,
like as many as one system or many
as many subsystems, and how we can use
maybe those formalisms to also deal with
policy making. That's very interesting
venue and the emergence of norms,
culture and ideas also. Because one
thing that I'm still struggling with in
the case of active insurance models is
like how to get outside the
checkerboard. You can put a
lot in the model, a priory,
and how you make the model,
creating new stuff that is not becked
inside. At the first and on that one
very interesting breakthrough was the
application of active inference to
morphogenesis. I really like the work
that has been done on that and on the
technical aspects. I think the two main
focus that I love are all the
deep active inference and how to scale
up active inference because it's a
strong limitation for the adoption of
the formalism if it's not scaled enough
compared to other framework like deep
learning and then the link with
empirical data. I really like, for
instance, the work of Ryan Smith and how
to connect with electrophysiology and
clinical data. And I think it's also
something very important to anchor the
theory in the real world and have
falsifiability and empirical validation
of those models. And what are some of
the applications of active inference to.
So? Well, I'm not the expert here. Karl
would be the best to answer that. But I
was referring to the work with Michael
Levin and how a model can help to
create a sort of embryogenesis.
So maybe, Karl, you can explain better
than me, please.
I don't have a reputation for explaining
things very clearly, but yeah,
that's absolutely right. It was just at
work with Michael Evan and colleagues
showing that you can get quite
expressive and bimimetic pattern
formation and movement of different
cells into an organization often
described in terms of morphogenesis
simply by communicating
your beliefs. So I'm coming back
to this sort of cross cutting theme of
communication. So if you just broadcast
your beliefs and you're a little cell
and there are a little ensemble of
cells, and they all have the shared
generative model that includes if
I was in this position, I would sense
that. Now, they all have exactly the
same generative model, the same
predictions, the same expectations, and
they're all broadcasting their beliefs
about where they are. And the free
energy minimizing solution is just when
they're all in a place such
that they receive signals that they
would expect to receive when they're in
this place. And of course, if that is
the same for everybody, there's only one
arrangement where each cell finds its
place. So basically, knowing your place
is an emergent property of making the
world mutually predictable through,
yeah, a deflationary account of
morphogenesis. But Gim,
I thought one of your units is precision
psychiatry. So I thought you're going to
talk about precision, so I'm going to do
a Guillem. Now, he talked about
morphogenesis, I'm going to talk about
precision. Now. I think that's
a really nice way just to pick up on
themes which everybody's just mentioned,
in particular the pathology of
precision. And by precision you can read
precision in the sense that Bert was
talking about in terms of do you use an
unsigned integer or a double? How much
can I coarse grain to my numeric
representation? Or you can use it in
terms of coarse grading in the sense of
the renormalization group chunking
things in hours or years as opposed to
milliseconds and minutes. Or you can
look at it in terms of a statistician
describing the reliability or the
inverse variance of a signal. And of
course we have to estimate that when I
say we I mean your agents and
statisticians and act accordingly.
And certainly in the work of
Ryan Smith on addiction, much of the
sort of mathematical explanation for
these addictive locked in OCD like
phenomena rests upon a failure to
get that course grading that precision
estimation right.
The reason I wonder whether it be just
worthwhile revisiting addiction
and psychopathology or certainly
pathology of behavior from the point of
view of getting precision wrong and
certainly assigning too much precision
to low level processing, which is what
Bert wants to avoid doing. It just
strikes me that that kind of story also
has mileage in terms of why we are
in a state of paralysis when it comes to
climate change because I also noticed,
Guillermo, that you talked about climate
action. I've never heard that before,
but that seems to me to be the important
thing. Why isn't there any climate,
Anna? You know, it'll be like you going
to the clinic and finding someone with
Parkinson's disease. Why isn't this
person moving?
And interestingly, the computational
explanation for Parkinson's disease is
assigning too much precision to the
evidence that you're not moving before
you move. So if you can't ignore
the fact that nothing is changing, all
your prior beliefs, your predictions
that I am going to stand up or going to
initiate walking, don't get a looking
because they are immediately cancelled
because you've assigned too much
precision to the lower level processing.
And I'm just wondering whether that kind
of pathology is exactly what
Ralph is trying to reverse by having
models at hand, recommendations at hand
that provide a more coarse grained view
of things, a deeper view.
Anna, would you like to comment on?
I love this idea of the pathology of
precision because I think it manifests
in so many different ways not
just among my patient population but I
think it's almost like a cultural
sickness, in a way.
The ways in which we seem, like obsessed
with certain types of data and we're
missing the big picture. So I'm going to
think more about that. I'm going to read
more about it. I really appreciate the
discussion. It's interesting for me and
Adam when. You'Re referring to the
pathology of precision, do you mean so
in a more conscious sense that we're
over evaluating something that we don't
need to? Whereas, Karl, you're referring
to it in an unconscious sense like the
brain is putting too much precision on
something because in Parkinson's it's
not like you consciously are putting
precision in a place. Well,
I think you could look at it sort of
like in both cases. When I think about
addiction, people aren't doing it
consciously. It's that they really do
see this as adaptive and healthy and
also even on some level that they can't
do otherwise. And they're not able to
see the true impact of their drug use on
their lives. They're genuinely not able
to see the negative consequences. And
that's what contributes to getting
caught in that vortex. But I mean,
you could also see it as part of what's
happened culturally. Like, for example,
the whole wellness industrial complex,
the way that we now count ourselves
through all these different devices.
And if we could just count our breathing
and count our heart rate and take
supplements, then we would somehow reach
some levitating state of precise
wellness. I don't know,
this is all kind of new ideas for me.
That's interesting. So you believe that
we can be inundated with health data and
that's detrimental to us? Oh,
absolutely. I see that all the time. So
for me, I used to have maybe I'll take
this out of the well, this is going out
live. Okay,
let me figure out how to say this
diplomatically. I used to have a device
that would measure my heart rate, let's
say that and my sleep. And instead of
improving my sleep, it led to me
becoming obsessed with it and then
noticing, oh, I didn't sleep well. I
must not be feeling good today as well
because apparently there's a high
connection between how your sleep
quality and. How well you plus added to
that the other layer that I should be
able to control it. Right. So with all
of this data and information, I should
be able to, I don't know, reduce free
entropy or whatever, reduce surprise,
as you guys talk about. And I think
that's obviously that only goes so far
and then can actually contribute to our
misery because why aren't we all
levitating like the Buddha or whatever
when we have all these tools and we can
pay attention to all this data? I see
this also with people who have
productivity tools. Not only that, but
mechanical keyboards. Let's say the
reason why I don't have a mechanical
keyboard, even though I think I'd love
it, is because I know that why the heck
do I care about the clicking sound of a
keyboard? But if I got one, then I'd be
like, well, what's the difference
between clicking sound A versus clicking
sound B versus clicking sound C? And I'd
become obsessed with the trappings of
productivity that is sharpening, so
called sharpening the axe rather than
cutting down the tree. There's this
phrase that is apocryphal. And it said
it's attributed to, I think,
Lincoln, which is that he'd spend 80% of
his time or half the time sharpening the
knife than cutting the tree.
And then this is just echoed in
productivity circles, but it can't be
the case. Why would you spend so much
time sharpening your axe? Like, look at
anyone who cuts down a tree with an axe.
Most of the time they're not doing that
anyhow. So if anyone has any comments on
what was just said, please can
I. Just talk what I find exciting in my
field about access? Sure, yes,
I read it's a long time ago, but there
was a paper and it's about that it says,
well, active inference is not really a
scientific loop because it's biased.
And I read that, and the
sound of the paper was kind of so it's
not good. But I think active inference
is maybe not a science loop. It's an
engineering loop because there's bias,
and we need bias in engineering. We need
to make stuff. We need to build stuff.
We need to have a bias. So it's an
engineering design cycle. I see that
everywhere around me.
And active inference could be a
complete breakthrough in in engineering.
Right. The fields around me
are signal processing. I am myself in a
signal processing department
or group, and everybody builds
algorithms. For us. In active inference
agents, it's inference over states.
Then the floor below me, they build
control systems. Well, it's inference
over actions. Then other people are
working on machine learning. It's
inference over parameters. Active
inference could be and you like this,
Kurt. It's a very deflationary view on
engineering, because everything is just
inference. And so rather than building
algorithms everywhere, if we become
really good at implementing
minimization, we will be
able to build a great engineering design
cycles, and we'll be engineering better
machines for
medical procedures or for other things
that are important. So it has a
tremendous application potential in
engineering. In engineering,
and I think in many fields, people have
sort of drifted in different directions.
Control theorists have. I mean, they do
almost the same thing as signal
processing people, but they speak a
different language. Now.
Signal processing people, it's a
completely different group for the
machine learning people, but it's all
information processing, and this field
can bring it together.
But the thing is that in order to make
it successful in engineering, we need to
build an application that
impresses. Right? It's not like a
TicTacToe thing. It really needs to
impress people, needs to be better than
some other control systems. But once we
do that, I think there is tremendous
application potential because there
haven't been enormous breakthroughs in
signal processing and control. The last
big breakthrough, I think, was Kalmont
filtering, and this was 1960s.
It's kind of funny that the essence of
what we do in active influence is also
carbon filtering.
I think there's tremendous opportunities
for what we do here for engineering.
That's why it's exciting to me. Anna,
do you mind expanding on what you said
about acting? And therapists should be
helping their patients with that. Oh,
sure. Just so. I mean, one of my
critiques of mental health treatment
today is that there's
not enough encouragement of patients to
actually go and act differently in the
world as a way of gathering data.
Instead, it often ends up being kind of
this world building between therapists
and patients, not necessarily ultimately
adaptive in the world. So I was really
just kind of responding to what Raft was
saying, that we need to act in the
world. I think that's more true now in
modern rich nations than ever before
because we are so incredibly sedentary
and interacting. Of course we're
interacting with a virtual world, and
that's good and bad. But I
think we need to be actually acting in
the world.
And so there's different forms of
therapy. As you know, there's talk
therapy, and then there's also cognitive
behavioral therapy or psychotherapy and
sort of talk therapy. But cognitive
behavioral therapy, as far as I
understand, focuses on the actions. Is
that incorrect? It also
focuses on model buildings. On the
cognition, again,
treating addiction. You're not going to
really get that far with cognitive
behavioral therapy or anything that's
focused on just emotions and cognitions.
People have to go out and actually try
stop using their stopping their
substance or their addictive behaviors
and gather data from that experience and
then come back and process it.
So, Anna, in your field and this
question will go to everyone, but in
your field and what you study, where is
the largest gap that you would like to
see closed? Well, I mean, we're facing a
huge mental health crisis now. We have
more and more young people coming in
with depression, anxiety, suicidality,
addictions of all sorts. And these are
not necessarily people who are
struggling by virtue of trauma or
socioeconomic disparity. These are
people who have really privileged lives
in many instances. So it's really a
puzzle what is going on for people. And
I think a big part of it is the fact
that people are not having embodied
experiences. They're not having
experiences in the world. And also
the experiences that they are having are
these kinds of very quick fixes and fast
pleasures.
Are you noticing? I think the co created
sort of models through healthier
communication that allow people to feel
part of a community and also to have
truthful co created narratives. Trying
to use the language here, I think that's
really important. So, for example, one
of the things Bert mentioned, what he's
excited about? One of the things I'm
excited about in the field of addiction
medicine is mutual support and the
proliferation of things like Alcoholics
Anonymous, but also other mutual help
groups, a lot of them existing now
online. And the way that people are
together creating healthier narratives
and acted together to counteract a
lot of the unhealthy narratives that I
think are driving a lot of decision
making today. I wanted
to know, is there a correlation between
the rise in mental health or, sorry,
mental illness or mental health issues,
whatever we want to call it, and a
certain trait of people? Is it
affecting the population the same?
So the whole population is raised 20% in
terms of how many mental health issues
they have per year? Or is it affecting
people who deal with abstractions more
and more? So, for instance, we're
talking over zoom and some people study
abstractions just like us. And then
there are some people whose work it is
to do something physical like running or
swim? Is it affecting everyone equally
or are you noticing that there's some
broad trend? Well, the broad trends that
are out there are just correlational,
but the more time that people spend in
the virtual world, the more likely they
are to suffer from depression, anxiety
and other mental health problems.
People haven't really been able to
narrow that down to specific content,
but they have been able to save just the
sheer amount of time that spending that
you're spending online increases your
risk for certain poor mental health
outcomes.
Okay. Now, Karl well, again, if anyone
has any comments or questions, please
just raise your physical hand. I can see
raph ralph raphael sorry. I was just
going to say that I think another
notable trend is, and I
just saw somebody say this on YouTube
just yesterday, that young people are
disproportionately affected by things
like climate grief because they're the
ones that are going to be alive to deal
with it. And I think
that applies more generally that Peter
Sanghi already like 30 years or
something ago, wrote about the
Inescapable Network of neutrality, the
reality that what
we do affects each other. Right?
And we took advantage of this huge
resource buffer that's called the
biosphere.
And. Earth to pretend that it didn't for
quite a long time and got a lot of
mileage out of it. But now we're at a
point where there's a whole generation
of people that are coming to grips with
the fact that I'm going to stop myself
from saying a square word, but oh my
God, we actually need to change
everything about everything that we do
and we need to do it fast. By the
way.
It's not just what we do out there,
it's also what we do inside, how we get
ready for how to show up for life
internally. Right? So no wonder that it
has that impact. Like myself, I've dealt
with anxiety and a lot of other
things. We've had conversations about
what are we doing bringing a daughter
into this world and all these kinds of
things. And I think it's only natural
that it's coming to a head in this way
right now. Naom you have your
hand up and I can't see yes.
Yeah, it's connect with what has just
been so and your initial
question about the gaps that needs to be
closed, I think like a scale free model
of health and mental health particularly
would be great. We are in silos,
in biomedical research and the fact that
someone is having depression can come
from interacting genes as much as
interacting people and also is
related to climate change and so on. So
how we can have a new health systems
that doesn't deal with those silos and
integrate those different scales, to me
it's like really a big challenge,
but a challenge that current models
and work that we can see going that
direction. And I'm very enthusiastic.
About that?
Bert.
Yeah. In my
field in engineering, active inference
is not understood because almost all
papers are written by neuroscientists
and they're hard to read. So I was
really happy to hear today that.
And I think it's Sanjeev Namjoshi who is
writing an engineering book on active
inference. So I think that will really
help. That, together with the
availability of good toolboxes for
implementing active inference, should
make a lot of engineers much more
enthusiastic about active inference
because it's not something that is
not understood at the moment in
engineering circles. So I hope that the
book will be good. I'm enthusiastic
about that. And Karl,
where are some gaps in your research
that you'd like to see?
More than gaps? There's a whole empty
space out there yet to be explored.
But in
terms of what seems to be emerging from
the session and specifically the past
few answers,
it does seem to be important to
have this very generic just to take
Bert's sort of line that this is
just one deflationary simple and
probably the right way to understand
stuff and to make recommendations or to
describe people's actions, possibly to
themselves in a therapeutic context.
And as such, it should be push button
technology and it should be democratized
and socialized. And I think that's the
challenge, practically. And 1 may ask,
why would you want to do that? For me,
there are two clear imperatives.
One is very abstract,
and it's not really within my comfort
zone, and the other one is in my comfort
zone. But the one that's outside my
comfort zone is this notion
of interactivity and hyperconnectivity
and the metacrisis that we heard about.
And Aguim also referred to this in terms
of what he was trying to distinguish
between a Californian notion of
optimality and another kind, another way
forward. And to me, it's a
stark contrast with growth is good
versus sustainability. And of course,
the math of the free energy principle is
just about sustainability. It's just a
description of the physics of systems,
random, dynamical systems that self
organize to some non equilibrium steady
state. That is what we are.
So for me, there's something deeply,
if you like, apt about the free energy
principle and its chronologies, such as
active inference in application to
ecosystems and lived ecosystems and
realized ecosystems. So if
those basic principles can be brought
back into globalization,
into the market, into fintech, into
social media, into politics, into
climate action, I think that would be a
good thing. I'm just mindful this struck
me in a number of the presentations
today. You remember before, Bert was
saying, if you look at the brain, which
is a really lovely example of a self
organizing system to a non equilibrium
steady state, then it's empty.
And what did he mean by that? What he
didn't mean you were empty headed. What
he meant was it's incredibly sparsely
connected. Now, that tells you
immediately that a pathology of
connectivity is hyperconnectivity
overconnectivity, which immediately,
well, it made me very alert to
the presentation of the metacrisis.
That one of the first three things that
was underwrote the metacrisis or
the current crisis we're tending with is
a destruction of that sparse, delicate
connectivity that defines thingness and
defines ensembles of things technically
in terms of Markov blankets. So if we
want a world in which lots of different
things can coexist in some kind of
generalized synchrony in a sustainable
way, you need fast connectivity.
And the pathology, the thing that will
destroy that, is overconnectivity. So it
seems to be very important that we get
that into play in terms of
machine learning, artificial
intelligence, politics, fintech,
climate change. And the only way it's
going to get there is epistemically by
equipping people to actually build their
own little models and ask their own
questions. You can't tell people this
they've got to learn they've got to
learn it for themselves. Just very
quickly, I'm sure we've only got a
couple of minutes left.
The other agenda, which I'm more
familiar with is exactly Anna's and
Guillaume's agenda, which is making this
work in the context of
neurology and psychiatry. So if you can
democratize and socialize this way
of describing things so that people can
now build models of their particular
patient in the other use of precision
psychiatry, I suspect that Guillum's
unit was called after. So it's a
personalized medicine that is really
personalized in the sense that you
actually have your digital twin of your
behavior. And then you've got that. You
optimize your digital twin to become a
model of your patient, and then you can
start to do experiments on that model,
behavioral interventions, or even share
that model very much in the spirit of
CBT with the patient and say, look,
this is you. This is what would happen
if you went out and did this. And this
is what would happen if you went out and
did that. To my mind.
And indeed, that was the initial
motivation for much of this work, was
actually to build observation models
of psychiatric conditions, to work out
both the pharmacological and
physiological basis and the disruption
of the pathology of precision and
message. Passing on the factographs that
are our brain even though they are very
empty on the one hand, but also get that
behavior, that key thing that Anna was
talking about the active engagement with
the lived world into that model
and hence active inference. And just to
conclude that that activity,
that sort of physical engagement, that
embodiment, that sort of for ease and
everything else, I think it's really
coming to a head now in terms of people
after, the large language model, after
the Chat GPT moment, the bounce back
has been what's missing? What's not
there? And of course, what is not there
is agency and embodied engagement with
the world. And that's why I think
there's still a lot of work to be done
in bringing artificial intelligence read
as active inference in a way
that matters to people who people
who can make a difference, which is
basically everybody, but specifically
politicians and doctors and engineers
and the like. So you all
now have 30 seconds to 60 seconds to
speak directly to the audience. What is
the message that you what closing
message do you have? You're speaking
directly to someone who's listening.
They're a curious person. They're
interested in active inference. They
also want to lead better lives,
hopefully, and do something
propitious. So what message do you have
for them? Anna, we'll start
with you.
Gosh. I'm just going to say what pops
into my mind right now is that one
of the things I have learned from my
patients who are trying to get into
recovery from severe addictions is
something that they call the set aside
prayer where they set aside all of the
notions that they have about how the
world works and try to be completely
open and receptive to information
coming into their minds. And I think
that's just a
wonderful frame or concept for all of
us living in the world to periodically
just take a moment and take these models
and just say everything I think I know
about the world, I'm going to
temporarily suspend it, and I'm just
going to be open. And when that happens,
we can be present and learn in a way
that it's not possible when we're just
trying to reinforce our models. Great.
Fantastic. And Bert. And then we'll go.
Karl. And then Raph and then Guillaume.
Well, I just enjoyed today very much. I
thought there was a lot of material,
both for people from, let's say,
psychology, neuroscience, but also for
engineers. So if you haven't watched
some of the talks, go look through the
schedule, because some of the talks were
really good, I think. So I really
enjoyed that. And then, yeah, what
should I tell people? Go work out. Do a
lot of sports. It's good for you.
Yeah. Sorry, I was going to make a joke,
but I can't because it wouldn't be.
So I'm going to use my 30 seconds just
to thank Daniel and his team for
this. If you want something to do,
you should go and watch the live streams
and get involved with this ecosystem.
I hadn't seen that paper being presented
before, but I was really impressed with
the Active Institute and its openness
and its welcoming attitude
and vision, like the Smithsonian.
So if you want to pursue these ideas,
get involved. And if you haven't got
time, just make sure you attend next
year's Active Inference Institute
celebration. But thank you, Daniel.
Raphael yeah. So I'll second what
Karl said and follow on with it's.
An invitation not just to participate
in the Active Defense Institute, but
also the invitation to participate in
building this Gaia tractor,
this new way of doing things that
acknowledges the value of growth, and
also the value of sustainability, joins
it all together in this thing called
regeneration. And it
really is a collective effort. It's a
collective learning effort.
And this also, by the way, also applies
to the panelists as well. I think.
Obviously, what Bert and Karl are doing,
it has immediate things that have to do
with what we're after. But one of
the main things that we keep discussing
is also like this the inter
subjectivity and the importance of being
able to operate well as humans together.
And that connects directly to cognitive
science in psychiatry. And so everybody
that wants to be engaged and
be a part of building a better world
should be thinking about what am I doing
as an individual or as employee
of organization or as a researcher or as
a leader or as a family member, what am
I doing? How does it contribute to this
new non equilibrium set of state?
So, yeah, that's kind of it. I probably
blew through the 60 seconds, but here it
is. And Guillaume,
well, I would thanks also, all of you
for the discussion and the organizer for
what they are doing. Indeed, the work of
the Active Inference Institute is very
laudable and interesting from an open
science perspective. They are really
embodying. That so big kudos to
them. And well, the Frieze was saying
to do sport is good for you. I'm not
very good at sports, but some say that
science is a team sport. So at least
have a good team perspective when doing
science. And being kind to each other
would be the best advice to everyone.
Well, thank you.
You get yours too. Somebody else has to
come in from outside the Markov blanket,
though. Well, I wanted to just thank
you, Daniel. Thank you, Daniel. And
Raphael and also Karl and Anna and Bert
and Yom. This was tremendous amount of
fun. And well, I hope I get to speak to
you all individually. And as usual, I
have way more questions than we were
able to get to. Thank you all.
Thanks. Thank you. Thanks everyone.
Farewell to the panelists. You're all.
Welcome back anytime. Thanks everybody,
for watching. Be watching. Right now
we're about to head over to the discord
and hang out and talk a little more if
you want to, and then stay involved,
get involved. So till next time.